[Music]
should i hold on to this or should i let
it go
and today's ambassador trash segment is
one of my items i happen to be wearing
it it's my favorite
t-shirt and if you're watching the video
version you'll see there's a picture of
me holding it in my
in my bedroom
but uh you can see it here tk me holding
it up in the bedroom but i'm also on
screen here i have a giant hole
that
sometimes people call it a nipple hole
it's not it's just a big hole in my
shoulder strategically placed because
it's it looks it's very close yeah
like that's what you wanted easy access
i didn't want the hole it just showed up
yeah
sure
well it's my favorite shirt but it's
only my favorite shirt oddly because all
my shirts are one of two brands uh i
this brand i have is called save khaki
and i've had this shirt for probably 10
years
and
the other brand that i
often wear is los angeles apparel
because they treat their workers fairly
and i like
their shirts
and this one i've had for a really long
time of course i can get rid of it and
it's no different from my other shirts
other than the fact that it has a hole
in it
and so
i'm not holding on to it because it has
a hole in it and it's also not truly my
favorite shirt in any other sense where
i'm clinging to it either
and so
tk if you're me or
patrons if you're in the live chat right
now let me know what it maybe you can
even vote on it where you put up a
youtube poll professor sean
what should josh do with his shirt
should he amass it or trash it what are
your thoughts tk i think first you
should write a poem about it
there's a hole
in the middle of my shirt dear eliza
dear eli
the transparency of my heart
my heart is open baby yes
can i can i make a r b song girl you
gotta let it go
i know your shirts got the whole
we actually have this meme
uh accidentally jordan was creating this
image
and we've been saying it for over a year
now
he does these minimal maxim images
and so the he accidentally juxtapo
juxtaposed two images together and so it
was like
uh are you going to
let go of those
things or whatever it was and the second
image was like something about um
the shirt that you wear right
and when they were accidentally spliced
together it said are you going to wear
that shirt
and
ever since then like we've been asking
that of each other but now it's the most
appropriate meme because it's like i'll
pull this out and i'll wear it just fine
on any non-podcasting day i just treat
it like any other shirt but on a
podcasting day generally if i put it on
i'm like uh oh i
i should wear some other shirt so you
will wear it though i wear it every week
yeah
so i only have about 10 shirts why would
you throw it away what's the argument
for because clearly you've got reasons
for keeping it you actually use it a lot
yeah
why would you throw it away
because i feel the pressure to throw it
away i feel as though it has become
obsolete
in a way
and we have a whole segment on here
called
obsolete objects and i don't know
whether or not it's obsolete we'll get
to that segment in a moment my shirt is
not the obsolete object yet
but
i think part of it has to do with the
pressure we feel because i'm totally
fine with the shirt i never even really
much pay attention to the hole that's in
it how could it possibly be obsolete
then hmm
did you enjoy this stand-alone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100 percent
advertisement free